[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire on va faire un saut
d'environ 80 ans dans le passé avec mes
deux invités du jour je reçois françois
guillaume lorrain pour son roman
scarlett qui raconte la préparation et
le tournage d' autant en emporte le vent
le plus grand film de tous les temps
selon les desiderata de son producteur
david o selznick et l'historien jean
lopez qui inaugure sa nouvelle
collection champs de bataille avec
kharkov 1942 le récit d'un désastre
militaire le dernier que connaîtra
l'armée rouge face aux allemands pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale mais
commençons d'abord par les images que
vous avez choisi tous les deux pour
illustrer notre époque jean lopez la
vôtre la voici
souvient du regard de cette petite fille
c'est une image qui à presque 40 ans
cette jeune fille dont on ignorait le
nom à l'époque elle a 12 ans a été
photographié par
un mccurry un grand photographe
américain et à l'époque elle est le
symbole de
du désastre humanitaire causée par
l'invasion soviétique de l'afghanistan
cette photo a été prise dans un camp de
réfugiés de l'autre côté de la frontière
pakistanaise
et cette personne qui à l'époque à 12
ans se marient de l'année d'après à 13
ans et elle a été retrouvée par mc cully
au moment où les américains eux
interviennent en afghanistan en 2002 il
a réussi à la retrouver après la eu de
nombreux déboires et au mois de novembre
dernier elle a été exfiltré
d'afghanistan après l'arrivée au pouvoir
des talibans et elle a trouvé refuge en
italie j'ai trouvé cette image
intéressante parce que à l'époque elle
était le symbole d'un désastre
humanitaire et on y parle guère les
soviétiques en était en pleine guerre
froide un
long l'art beaucoup revu ces derniers
temps dans la presse américaine quand
les américains ont quitté le pays et
elle a pris une toute autre tournure
puisque elle est devenue le symbole
féministes du refus de l'oppression
obscurantistes des talibans contre les
femmes donc la même icône à 40 ans
d'écart avec deux interventions
complètement différentes et pas mis en
cause de la même façon prend des
significations très différentes et est
alors moi je dis que le vert de ses yeux
n'était pas le vrai alors
aussi de est ce qu'on peut faire
confiance aux images le problème de ma
femme s'éprend de ma cure il est génial
qu'une expo qui à paris au musée maillol
la mc curry a été épinglé plusieurs fois
pour avoir un peu touché retoucher ses
images et chaque fois il répond mais je
ne suis pas photojournaliste ce
photographe ça veut dire je m'autorise à
s'attendre de licence alors pour le
verre je ne sais pas je sais que quand
ils ont retrouvé cette femme en 2002
les américains ont fait faire une
analyse de lyrisme et ça c'est c'est
indépendant de la couleur en fait ouais
donc ils ont identifié par son lyrisme
et pas par la couleur la photo qu'on
voie d'eau mais aujourd'hui il ya 50 ans
est passée c'est une femme de 50 ans et
son visage a complètement changé mais
elle a toujours un éclat singulier dans
les yeux dans les yeux même si les
maraudes est un peu
un peu plus tôt funny votre image avoue
françois guillaume lorrain
malheureusement bien connu oui c'est une
image qui date d'il ya maintenant six
ans en 2015 sur les rivages turc c'est
un c'est un enfant qui faisait partie
d'une cargaison ou à dire de migrants
syriens qui tentaient de rallier la
grèce qui était rabattu sur les rivages
turc ça a été une photo prise par une
femme une journaliste turque qui étaient
là à couvrir les évènements
elle me fera beaucoup parce qu'elle est
elle et à l'articulation de deux choses
d'abord la dimension l'ère moderne
évidemment des guerres actuelles
qui touche les civils et la cua innocent
copie
pure qu'un enfant qui est touchée qui
n'avaient rien à faire évidemment
surtout pas aussi à quitter son pays
d'abord ancien et avec lunaire beaucoup
plus actuelle qui est
à la fois
cette image une image a fait le tour du
monde en quelques en quelques heures
donc on est là dans le village
médiatique camp dans lequel on
appartient avec une indignation
immédiate
on voit bien aussi pourquoi elle est là
elle a fonctionné que de manière aussi
forte un enfant sur une plage
normalement ces sont des dimensions de
plaisir le loisir
de détente d'insouciance et là tout est
renversée évidemment
une indignation qui en même temps n'a
pas empêché l'impuissance en fait c'est
ça c'est les leurs vers ça c'est à dire
que on s'indigne tous mais on ne fait
rien et tout continue et donc c'est
cette voie là c'est cette image m'a
comme beaucoup m'a toujours
beaucoup exercé je crois qu'elle
continuerait de bouleverser on s'en
souviendra effectivement encore dans
longtemps et bien commençons
[Musique]
enfin guillaume lorrain vous êtes
l'auteur de l'année des volcans c'était
sur le tournage de stromboli réalisé par
roberto rossellini avec l'actrice ingrid
bergman qui allait devenir sa femme
scarlett qui vient de paraître chez
flammarion c'est le récit de
l'adaptation cinématographique d'autant
en emporte le vent le plus gros
best-sellers de l'histoire des états
unis alors autant en emporte le vent
c'est d'abord une histoire de femme
c'est une femme la journaliste margaret
mitchell qui met dix ans à écrire les
mille pages de ce gros roman qu'elle
pense à vendable c'est une femme son ami
le xdrive cole qui persuade son patron
chez mcmillan de l'éditer ce sont les
femmes qui entoure les qui les entourent
qui pousse les producteurs hollywoodiens
à se battre pour acheter les droits et
david hauss elle nick qui finit par les
obtenir il est poussé par deux femmes
cameron qui lui fait un rapport de
lecture dithyrambiques et sa propre
femme qui a dévoré le roman lui ne l'a
même pas lui non parce qu'il a dix 10
projets sur le feu il est en train de
finir un tournage avec difficulté avec
marlene dietrich qui lui pose beaucoup
de problèmes dans le désert ils sont en
train de suer sang et eau n est pas du
tout contente de ce qu'il écrit parce
qu'il est aussi scénariste un côté qu'il
était un peu tôt cet homme là comme les
vrais gros producteurs de lait
prioritaire en scène aussi frustré rabat
et donc il n'a pas le temps il h et puis
surtout il n'est pas convaincu par une
chose tu es découverte c'est que
d'ailleurs personne à ce moment là n'en
veut c'est que la guerre de sécession a
toujours été un flop au cinéma jusque là
ça renvoie les américains évidemment
alors à leurs blessures à leurs guerres
civiles donc tout le monde
voilà il faut attendre vraiment que le
best-seller traîne mais il y va
contraints et forcés ils achèveront
allez on va lâcher 50000 $ et on verra
bien mais il est un peu embarrassé et
mervans qui comprend vite que la
fascination qu'exerce le livre sur les
lectrices parce que c'est d'abord les
lectrices qui se précipitent sur autant
en emporte le vent à l'époque cette
phase in action elle est due avant tout
aux personnages de scarlett le problème
maintenant c'est qu'il va falloir
l'incarner scarlett exactement il ya 1
promenade d'actrice juste rappeler qui
est celle ci n'est qu'à ce moment là
c'est disons c'est le dernier fondateur
dans la halle grande lignée des
fondateurs des grands studios américains
c'est l'homme le plus brillant mais qui
a toujours travaillé jusque là pour des
patrons louis b meyer qui sont en plus
son beau père le fondateur de la mgm il
a travaillé pour la paramount il a
travaillé pour d'autres encore donc ces
producteurs il faut le dire ce
producteur de king kong aussi quand il
travaillait pour la 1ère classe et
producteur des chasses du comte zaroff
de deux têtes film très très haut mais
il a toujours travaillé un moment pour
d'autres il a été le second est en 35 il
vient de claquer la porte à son
beau-père pour fonder sa propre maison
de production c'est les productions avec
l'idée c'est un peu la clé une des clés
du personnage de venger son père qui
était déjà un producteur très en vue
dans les années 20 et qui avait été
ruinée justement par ses fondateurs donc
c'est ligue derrière sa folie c'est
l'histoire d'un fils qui va venger le
père et qui va essayer d'en montrer en
remontre à tout le monde et et ça va
être l'occasion il va le découvrir petit
à petit qu'il a l'occasion avec ce ce
cadeau empoisonné au départ peut-être de
tous les écraser alors il ya vous
décrivez bien ce que ce que ce que lui
appelle le syndrome scarlett c'est à
dire qu'à partir du moment où on
commence à parler de l'adaptation du
cinématographique de ce best-seller que
toutes les femmes vous etats unis sont
en train de dévorer
ici à toutes les actrices qui sont
persuadés qu' elles sont scarlett eric
eux mêmes que margaret mitchell a écrit
ce roman % elle oui alors il reçoit des
lettres de cantat des candidatures
spontanées
après il va y avoir des problèmes pour
lui parce qu'il n'a pas d'actrice il est
obligé de les emprunter oui oui la
bénoué salle est né dans le site
salariés les studios en fait tu possèdes
mais vraiment comme des esclaves quand
tu es joueur de foot plus exactement
comme des voilà il ya des mercato il ya
des travaux s'ils sont prêts à payer si
vous avez très bien et c'est des
esclaves très bien payé et donc par
exemple ça va être le cas là un problème
avec bette davis bette davis qui veut
jouer le rôle mais jack warner veut la
refiler avec errol flynn dans le rôle de
rhett butler on va l'avoir bette davis
jusqu'au bout
et baisser ce qui a son franc parler qui
en procès plus ou moins avec warner dit
pas question de tourner avec cette ce
couillon ce castres heures de moutons
parce qu'en fait c'était le premier
métier de des rôles fidh en australie
donc hop à la trappe mais ça fait
capoter par exemple bette davis il va il
faut quand même jezebel we un film sur
la guerre de sécession
vers le basket voilà ont commencé que
s'expliquer très très lent que toute
cette histoire va quand même duré trois
quatre ans on va le prendre de vitesse
katherine hepburn elle y va parce
qu'elle est en perte de vitesse mais en
plus elle l a reçue de margaret mitchell
quand même c'est la seule une dédicace
elle a pensé à elle donc là il ya quand
même une une raison mais mais ils
connaissent très très bien avec saisie
que ces saisies qui a lancé catherine ed
byrne 5 6 1 avant et ils s'aiment pas du
tout ils s'aiment pas du tout et
l'entretien avait juste vu que ça se
passait pas bien moi j'essaie de
redonner un peu tout ce qui se passe est
remis entre 2
d'être une mouche ça voilà donc il en
surgit et marca il ya des qu'amusant il
ya le capital ou la blanquette de par
exemple où la blanquette sudiste ouais
alors c'était une sacré personnage qu'on
a un peu oublié aujourd'hui mais c'était
une ravageuse c'est un peu errol flynn
au féminin une croqueuse croqueuse
d'hommes et mais elle a un avantage
c'est qu'elle est sudiste et scarlett
est une soliste et en plus elle a un
père qui est un homme politique
important et il va y avoir une campagne
électorale pour elle en fait on va voir
que tout ça va dériver vers une campagne
presque présidentielle puisque c'est le
smic va avoir d'autres stratégies
pendant deux trois ans pour faire durer
le suspense qui ne va pas passer
simplement par des actrices mais par des
inconnus et donc comme ça il ya des
campagnes mais chacun va vouloir son
actrice il va y avoir les deux grandes
et côtières oui il ya et d'ailleurs
hopper et où est la parsons et dire que
ces lois là parsons qui lance tellement
la blanquette et immédiatement et d'un
père rémy alors guérilla mopti meriam
hopkins qui aime avoir la qui est là lui
mais qui ne veut pas qui est aussi une
sudiste mais qui n'aime pas du tout le
l'image que donne un peu rétrograde un
peu esclavagiste évidemment du sud que
john mitchell qui dit non non non vous
pouvez faire croire que vous voulez hein
mais moi j'irais pas viacom ça d'autres
qui défilent et puis à un moment csdhi
qu'ils y il faut quelque chose un regard
neuf un visage neuf je vais lancer son
côté pygmalion tout le monde défile mais
non non non ça va être quelqu'un d'autre
et vous avez une espèce de campagne de
recrutement national tout le monde a le
droit d'envoyer ses idées sa la bougie
strictement à rien oui mais c'est c'est
une folie qui va prendre vous imaginez
qu'en fait dans toutes les grandes
villes des états unis un peu comme
aujourd'hui avec de voice ou ou bien
d'autres émissions des milliers de
femmes vont se retrouver dans des
d'abord dans des salles de cinéma pour
être choisi sélectionnés puis vont
passer des essais qui vont être
enregistrées puis envoyés à hollywood en
fait il conçoit le premier film
qu'il appelle démocratique participatif
en faisant croire que elles vont pouvoir
être à la place de leurs stars et de
leur héroïne et les carnets l'oreille
mais en même temps c'est tout bon tu
deviens fou george cukor qui est
normalement le réalisateur de 2 d'autant
en emporte le vent aux menaces de mort
enfin oui il raconte une histoire dans
dans d'angie retrouver une histoire dans
sa biographie en fait ils retrouvent une
fille
a atlanta qui l'a déjà casté à new york
et qui le poursuit après sur le quai de
métro sur lequel train parce qu'il
reprend un très bas ce qui fait toute la
tournée lui aussi pour que castet et
donc il est obligé de lachuer enfin il
lui arrive d d d d d pérégrinations des
aventures complètement dingue donc ils
se rendent compte qu'en fait ils ont
allumé une mèche une bombe il ya des
écarts il ya déjà des viols il ya dans
l'est parce qu'il ya des faux casting et
des gens qui sont passés pour des pour
des équipes de selznick il ya aussi des
histoires d'argent de corruption donc on
essaie de faire payer les gens les
filles alors en même temps qu'il ya ça
il supervise aussi le celtic
l'adaptation parce qu'il faut quand même
transformer les 1000 pages du roman
en en un film alors un film qui va être
d'une longueur exceptionnelle mais quand
même il faut conserver tout ce qui fait
l'intérêt c'est une
c'est une véritable usine qui se met à
désosser le desk se compare à un peu à
la au système
fordien à l'époque parce que donc il ya
il ya plus de cinq mille costumes il ya
80 scènes ya des décors à n'en plus
finir donc il va s'entourer des plus
grands
experts techniciens de l'époque lui
c'est le règne du quoi qu'il en coûte 1
c'est vraiment tout est ouvert
et donc il va aussi supervisé toute une
équipe de scénaristes mais ça il a un
peu l'habitude parce que voilà c'est la
ccc le système où il ya un premier
scénariste principal servi par un 2ème
3ème 4ème et lui y passe mais ça ça va
quoi là où c'est là qu'on barrios plaît
c'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui sur les
séries exactement et il va la porter à
l'incandescence il va effrayer tout le
monde parce que il va inventer quelque
chose qui est assez drôle c'est qu'il va
y avoir plusieurs couleurs de scénario
au moment du tournage c'est à dire que
plus ou moins refait traire fait au
dernier moment et les acteurs - dans une
panique généralisée tout le temps mais
alors il ya une chose qu'il faut
comprendre aussi c'est pourquoi il fait
durer le
ce casting pendant deux trois ans c'est
qu'il a un problème parce que il ya un
autre problème cc clark gable
ou on n'imagine pas un autre que la
gueule pour red dot l'heure mais lui
n'en veut pas parce qu'alors que tout le
monde vous veux et voilà que déboule
dans le rôle de bois c'est que google
appartient à son beau père or il a
justement claqué la porte du boupère
c'est pas pour en plus retourner chez le
beau père choc le beau-père il va
vouloir entrer dans le film on échange
de gamme tribution et coproductions donc
en gros c'est ceci milliers devant le
beau père et donc il va tout tenter il a
tenté cooper kiss à ne pas en vouloir et
un moment il se dit bon d'accord je vais
pas coupé à cooper à google et ça
implique un accord de distribution qui
le bloque pendant deux trois ans donc et
et moi ce que j'aime beaucoup dans ces
histoires chéché celtics qui à la fois
le mélange
de pragmatisme commercial de négociation
à n'en plus finir donc là de contraintes
et puis quand même l'idée d'un pygmalion
qu'il veut trouver la perle rare qu'un
badaud qui attendent miracle qui atteint
miraki qui se dit mais non c'est jamais
ça sait jamais ce à un moment ça va être
peut l'être goddam le cas pour les
godard est très intéressante parce que
paulette goddard c'est la femme de
chaplin elle a joué dans elle a joué
dans les temps modernes et elle a joué
dans le elle va jouer dans le dictateur
que tu es chaplin va incessamment dot
hill incessamment débuter le tournage et
paulette goddard elle tient la corde
pascal et
je regarde tous les sels et juive et la
ccar d une fille du sud vis-à-vis des
déchus disent oui c est ce qu a appris
qu'elle geodis à prier oui alors là oui
parce que en fait il est très convaincu
il va un dîner parce que j'ai découvert
qu'en fait chaplin et son voisin à
hollywood chaplin des tests selznick il
déteste les dîners en ville mais godard
qui veut absolument voir le rôle du
chaplin écoute parler ça plaît chez nous
un dîner avec avec sonic et puis que je
puisse a vraiment développer déployer
tous mes chats et c'est intéressant
parce que ceci tient à ce moment-là
l'huile en plein préparation du
dictateur donc il est vraiment
préoccupée par ce qui se passe dans le
monde ce qui va se dérouler et voilà
hollywood et l'amérique n'est plus
occupé que d'une chose qui va devenir
scarlett est donc et alors ils pensent
la prendre et puis il ya un de ses
collègues qui est dit mais au fait est
ce qu'elle est mariée vraiment parce
qu'il ya des rumeurs qui disent qu'ils
sont pas mariés il a une mauvaise
réputation de chaplin et donc il va
passer du temps avec elle
avec ses avocats à vérifier et à
constater qu'elle n'est pas mariée donc
s'il fait ce rôle avec une femme en
concubinage y voir toutes les ligues de
femmes qui vont lui tomber dessus alors
et puis il ya le miracle qui arrive
c'est viviane lee est alors la légende
de 10 vous reprenez la légende que la
légende est fondée oui c'est ça viviani
elle vient elle veut ce rôle elle aussi
mais elle est anglaise elle vit à
hollywood où tourner son son amant
laurence olivier avec elle n'est pas
encore mariée elle le sera plus tard et
elle a dans la poche le frère de david
ocldi mayron qui est un très très grand
agent et il va la présenter à son frère
sur le set du tournage le premier jour
de tournage d' autant en emporte le vent
le film commence on n'a toujours pas
scarlett et on brûle tous les décors
pour faire la sodida la grande scène et
ce serait sur ce set qu'il aurait
présenté ses selles serait apparue avec
les
j'ai croisé absolument toutes les
sources américaines enfin toutes les a
toutes les archives c'est bien là moi ce
qui m'a intéressé aussi c'est que
viviane lit donc vous avez quelqu'un qui
kane qui est le rêve comme ça d'une
autre actrice d'un visage dont il n'a
pas les contours mais il sait que c'est
jamais ça jusque jusqu'à ce jour là et
puis des 36 c'est à dire trois ans avant
une actrice anglaise inconnu qu il y
livre et qui se dit
c'est moi c'est pour moi et qui pendant
deux trois ans va intriguer va va
refuser des rôles et et va se servir de
son amant laurence olivier pour comme
strapontin comme marchepied elle a une
chance folle
l'agent de laurence olivier et le propre
frère de celle-ci est comme ça petit à
petit alors que c'est l'unique va
l'avoir vu dans un chimie les pas
convaincu
elle va arriver au bon moment parce que
si elle va à hollywood c'est pas pour
aller voir son amant c'est vraiment pour
être là avec marianne saisie et alors il
la prépare marianne s'est dit presque il
ya un personnage mois que j'ai découvert
aussi c'est se mariant musique qui lui
veut venger ses deux frères je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure les ferventes lui
veut faire imploser le système des
studios avec le système des agents c'est
normal les acteurs réalisateurs il
anticipe quelque chose qui leur aura
lieu les 20 ans les agents n'ont pas
intérêt à ce que les acteurs soient
salariés parce qu'elle soit là je suis
rôle dans le rôle est réduit à portion
congrue évidemment avec le tournage
alors on prend une nouvelle dimension
que prend le film puisqu'il va falloir
changer de réalisateur au milieu il va
falloir faire évoluer le scénario et il
va y avoir des problèmes avec clark
gable l'éveil à voir il va y avoir en
fait à tournage à la hauteur de vue plus
grands films de l'histoire du cinéma que
voulait produire oui parce qu'alors lui
s'éteint celle des techniques de tout
contrôler on voit bien qu'il ya des
problèmes entre viviane league connaît
le libre parker et fleming qui a
remplacé cukor kiel le meilleur ami de
gueumbeul gemmell à fait
sauter du corps
scénique a bien compris qu'il faut un
réalisateur carrément qu'il ya un
souffle épique et que corps et d'un
médiateur
hatim east en plus que corps c'est qui
est un homosexuel notoire
add des informations sur des relations
éventuellement homosexuels de gueule est
donc belle ne supporte pas qu corps mais
après li ne supporte pas fleming qui lui
dit un bijou avec tes seins qui nous
emmerde avec le touch ton livre parce
qu'elle cite tout le temps livré le
livre a été quand même assez cru que
haché et donc il ya y partent parfois
face à ces décès des grandes scènes de
de querelles et et il ya moyen une scène
qui m'a beaucoup marqué on a un peu
oublié mais qui est un viol conjugal
dans des roms dans le dans le le livre
et de rang le film c'est quand gemmell
quand red bud leur viol ça à sa propre
femme et moi j'ai découvert une chose en
travaillant dans les
du côté américain c'est que gemmell à ce
moment là on commence à se savoir dans
le milieu qu'il l'a violée lui aussi une
grande actrice mais ramon qui ne
savaient qu'il est un enfant leur taille
ou leur adhésion parlant et donc j'ai
trouvé ça aussi très intéressant qui les
a à jouer cette scène là du viol et donc
il ya toute une ambiance extrêmement
malsaine qui se développe sur le
tournage avec un gameplay qui est très
mal à l'aise et on pour ma part je
trouve qu'il n'est pas alors toutes les
filles toutes les femmes sont tombées
amoureuses de lui mais je pense que la
grande actrice et elle elle mange le
film est donc c'est un c'est un tournage
qui d'ailleurs m'en manque de
s'interrompt plusieurs fois qui dépasse
ce que tous les crédits tous les
toutous les budgets mais c'est
intéressant de voir aussi que ce film
qui aujourd'hui encore par les
américains est considéré comme leur plus
grand film
aurait pu très bien ne jamais avoir lieu
et d'aller derrière en fait tout un peu
le rêve en technicolor qu'il propose
pour pour voir un peu ce qui s'est
vraiment passé je pense que c'est ça le
propre du cinéma 1 c'est c'est un
mélange d'art et de et de vie tous un
homme de passion de choses très vivant
un dernier mot parce qu'on va
s'interrompre pour la pause il ya une
actrice c'est haïti bac daniel à qui
vous consacrez beaucoup de chapitres
dans ce livre qui est l'actrice noire
qui tient le rôle de la domestique
esclaves de viviane li ti mcdaniels qui
va avoir l'oscar du meilleur second rôle
féminin elle est la première femme
afro-américaine à avoir un oscar elle
n'a pas pu rentrer dans le cinéma le
jour de la première parce que c'était
attentes avec le cinéma était réservée
aux blancs pour l'oscar c'est dans un
hôtel qui pratiquent la série des
ségrégations mais on lui autorise
exceptionnellement s'asseoir au fond à
une table séparer et puis ensuite quand
il ya la fête dans la boîte de nuit
évidemment elle ne peut pas rentrer
parce qu'elle est noire hattie mcdaniel
c'est un très grand symbole aux états
unis dans la communauté aujourd'hui oui
et ce qui m'intéressait c'était de
revenir à la source et de raconter en
fait que tous les débats qui a déjà dans
les 1 30 dans la communauté noire ce que
le film est scrutée de très très près
par la commune et moi il ya tous les
tout là tout le spectre en fait ya ya ya
les modérés et les radicaux et quelle
est sa place à l'ailé prises entre les
deux ont fait elle veut participer au
système elle veut montrer elle veut
travailler l'état triche elle dit
travaille énormément oui mais plutôt des
jusque là des tout petits rôles et elle
dit je préfère être jouée une domestique
en êtres humains parce qu'elle l'a été
et mais elle est très attaquée par les
radicaux noir à l'époque et donc
j'essaie de raconter en fait tout ce
débat et quand elles arrivent vous
faisiez allusion aux oscars il ya une
manifestation contre elle à l'entrée
mais c'est une addition de noir qui est
qui qui la traitent de collabo et de qui
lui reprochent de pactiser
avec les blancs il faut savoir que
récemment sur netflix autant en emporte
le vent a été enlevé parce qu ils
véhiculeraient des des clichés racistes
de l'époque et le scénic lui il reçoit
beaucoup de lettres justement de gens
très très engagé dans la défense des des
gens de couleur il leur dit alors il est
assez il est assez malin il a dit écoute
et moi je suis d'une race persécutés je
vous comprends très bien
mais il enlève pas tout la vision
esclavagiste ils enlèvent des scènes
comme le ku klux klan des choses comme
ça mais elle aussi va je raconte ça un
peu va derrière un peu et oeuvrer pour
des consignes de travail c'est de
raconter aussi ce que c'est qu'être un
noir au cinéma dans cinéma américain
c'est pas évident c'est pas les mêmes
conditions de travail que les blancs et
j'ai dit une bêtise comme le rappelle
dans l'oreillette c'est pas sûr et
netflix qu'on a enlevé autant en emporte
le vent mauvais sur hb ou de max voilà
le roman s'intitule scarlett il vient de
paraître chez flammarion ont fait une
pause et on se retrouve juste après avec
jean lopez
[Musique]
jean lopez vous vous êtes historien
directeur de la rédaction du magazine
guéret histoire est l'auteur de nombreux
livres de référence sur la seconde
guerre mondiale et vous dirigez une
nouvelle collection chez perrin vous
êtes inauguré avec kharkov 1942 le récit
d'une offensive soviétique qui tourne au
désastre en 48 heures en ukraine en mai
1942 cette bataille oublier c'est le
dernier désastre que connaîtra l'armée
rouge face aux allemands
pourquoi est-ce que vous en avez fait un
livre d'histoire forcément à paris vous
auriez pu en faire un roman il suffisait
de rajouter quelques quelques dialogues
ici et là je ne pense pas avoir le
l'imagination de français guillaume
malheureusement oui mais du business je
vous rends hommage parce que c'est une
question qu'on a envie de vous poser
effectivement c'était il ya écrit romo
sur la couverture mais mes chats travail
je suis une biographie romancée oui mais
n'était pas pardon un genre mais c'est
moi je suis à la fois historien et
romancier et donc je travaille toujours
je commence comme un historien et après
un moment je bascule un romancier parce
que j'ai un peu j'ai toujours autant
envie d'être la mouche est de savoir
exactement ce qui se passe derrière la
porte et ce qui s'est dit et fait
revivre en fait voilà donc je suis je
suis schizophrène totalement et j'assume
cette schizophrénie siège bascule à un
moment et c'est ça qui m'excite c'est à
dire de restituer complètement la jv
d'inventer ce que vous ne savez pas
voilà d'amendé parce qu'on a en fait les
biographies le tout le travail
d'historien pour moi c'est des points de
suspension et et c'est un peu c'est très
sec voilà alors vous jean lopez pourquoi
vous avez eu envie de consacrer 300
pages à cette bataille quasiment oubliés
de l'histoire de la seconde guerre
mondiale non parce que j'en ai fait pas
mal c'est la manquer à mettre en place
et je trouvais intéressant qu'on reparle
peut-être de l'ukraine qui est un point
de tension juste de ce que vous rappeler
que cette ville-là qui est aujourd'hui
tout près de la zone contestée on va
voir ghetto du dombass où elle est par
rapport à moscou déjà c'est certainement
la grande la grande ville de l'est de
l'ukraine en tout cas c'est la pelure
utilisé on va dire et c'est celle aussi
qui n'a plus disputé la seconde guerre
mondiale réussi cinq batailles ont
quatre absolument majeur ils sont
déroulées pour le contrôle de cette très
grande ville industrielle qui ébranle le
joyau économique de l'ukraine dont vous
dites d'ailleurs qu'aucune de ces
batailles ne s'est jamais déroulé dans
kharkov à elles sont toujours en dehors
elles sont en demande en sauf en dehors
de kharkov il s'agit d'examiner pour car
quand ils font s'est pas battu à kharkov
mais pourquoi est ce qu'on sait autant
battus pour kharkov en quoi elle est une
ville industrielle ok mais à part ça
elle est une grande ville industrielle
ce qu'on ne voit pas sur la carte c'est
un grand carrefour ferroviaire elle est
équipée chose très rare en russie de
piste d'aérodrome en béton étonné est là
elle a tous les attributs d'une
métropole d'un très important et puis
elle est elle est l'endroit où les
allemands ont massé une quantité de
dépôt incroyable les hôpitaux les
athéniens fin tout service in énorme que
qui accompagnent les armées modernes est
concentrée à kharkov perdre et kharkov
pour les allemands seraient quelque
chose extrêmement grave ça gênerait les
requêtes ferroviaire nord-sud et
est-ouest
moi je vous passe le produit les joueurs
au point de vue logistique c'est
vraiment quelque chose de majeur et pour
pour pour staline c'est aussi un
objectif très important parce que c'est
quand même la cinquième ville de l'union
soviétique c'est pas rien kharkov mais
c'est drôle d'ailleurs appuyé ce que
vous dites c'est la ville la plus
disputés de l'histoire de la seconde
guerre mondiale
on se souvient de spain grade on se
souvient de leningrad pourparlers gilles
du front de l'est on est tous oubliés
car colle absolument absolument et ça
c'est d'ailleurs là ben laden à partie
de cette nouvelle collection est
consacrée à la résidence longue à la
mémoire de la bataille cette mémoire est
extraordinairement faible elle est juste
entretenue chez les allemands mais même
pas pas celle-là pas la 2e et la 4e
bataille de kerkhof celle qu aura lieu
en mars 43 et entre riches et allemand
ce qu'elle a donné lieu à
l'établissement de la légende de match
times comme le grand génie de la seconde
guerre mondiale mais c'est tout pour le
reste c'est vrai que elle est
complètement oubliée elle était sûre
oublié parce que elle est aujourd'hui
dans une zone qui est âprement disputée
en termes mémorielle on voit bien que
les russes et les ukrainiens n'ont pas
la mémoire la même mémoire profit ciel
de la seconde guerre mondiale et dans
ces conditions kharkov et dans un
terrain extrêmement polarisé aujourd'hui
les résoudre je pense aux noms
supplémentaires pour qu'elles soient
ensevelis sous une telle obscurité les
deux parties peuvent pas se mettre
d'accord sur l'importance mémorielle à
lui accordez vous le vous le dit aussi
c'est le dernier la troisième bataille
de kharkov celle dont nous occuper dans
ce livre ce sera le dernier des astres
que d'être à l'armée rouge à partir de
là ils vont gagner pas tout à fait
disons que c'est la dernière fois qu'ils
sont humiliés complètement c'est-à-dire
battu de manière extrêmement cher un
sèche indiscutable en ayant une large
supériorité de moyens ils sont battus
par beaucoup plus adroits beaucoup plus
forts qu'eux ils auront une autre
défaite importante un peu plus tard que
celle de sébastopol mais il considère
que c'est un peu là une défaite
glorieuses dont nous les français nous
sommes particulièrement friands les
soviétiques ont la leur ces sébastopol
qui s'est défendu alors là un contre 3
ou 4 et capte lui très très longtemps
donc c'est plutôt pour l'épauler
soviétique c'est un peu une sorte de
répétition générale de l'héroïsme de
masse de stalingrad mais ça kharkov donc
oublier chape de silence à l'époque et
jusqu'à aujourd'hui alloway secours sont
l'armée allemande et l'armée rouge en
mai 42 au moment de la troisième
bataille de kharkov et plus exactement
où en sont quittes l'air et staline
alors hitler évidemment une déconvenue
rentable parce que villa tout jouer sur
l' attaque surprise de barbaros anchois
41 il est persuadé que les revers
initiaux
si fort que l'armée rouge sera décapité
et il ajoute que probablement le régime
bolchévique va s'effondrer dans la
foulée il n'est pas le seul à avoir
cette analyse puisque quasiment le monde
entier à cette analyse churchill et
roosevelt les premiers sont persuadés
que à la noël 1941 il y aura plus
d'armée rouge il y aura plus d'union
soviétique et il y aura plus de staline
le monde entier considère que c'est un
régime extraordinairement fragile qui ne
tient que par la terreur d'une petite
minorité sur une grande majorité qui est
d'accueillir les allemands à dire que le
les revers militaires qui ont été ceux
des soviétiques dans six premiers mois
de leur père à sion barbarossa vont dans
ce sens personne n'a imaginé ce
moment-là qu'il puisse y avoir on n'a
jamais vu dans l'histoire de l'histoire
militaire une armée de la taille de
l'armée rouge qui est détruite deux fois
entièrement deux fois reconstruite et
qui arrive in extremis de aux portes de
sa capitale à bloquer l'offensive d'une
armée qui est pour supérieur donc
toujours est il que l'échec de
l'opération barbarossa en décembre 41
obligy clair à remettre en remettre une
couche en 42 il espère que cette fois ci
en se fondant sur les pertes énormes de
l'armée soviétique il espère qu'une
nouvelle saignée va lui permettre si ce
n'est
de précipiter la chute du régime
soviétique ce donjon sont à l'époque il
commence à douter mais au moins à
renvoyer les russes très loin derrière
la volga il faut il faut bien voir qu'à
ce moment là aujourd'hui les historiens
que vous le savent iker ne peut plus
gagner la guerre en étant en aurait 42
il ya les américains
qui sont entrés en guerre après par la
mort les russes ont réussi à l'arrêter
c'est foutu alors s'il peut plus gagner
mais mais il a ce ne sera jamais qu'il a
perdu mais ça ne signifie pas qu'il a
perdu voilà c'est dire qu'il peut plus
gagner il peut rêver à un pacte
d'ailleurs il va en parler mais ça avec
mussolini il en parle avec un certain
nombre de ses maréchaux éventuellement
on pourrait arriver à une sorte leur
pend 42 à 48 pense qu'il a encore une
chance mais l'année lapointe 43 il va
peut-être penser qu'à un moment donné un
accord est peut-être possible sauf qu'il
fasse rapport aux actes staline a
peut-être lui là les sources
malheureusement font cruellement défaut
sally lui a peut-être avancer une petite
patte aussi de sonder son ennemi préféré
toujours est il que en
à la fin de descendre 41 les armées
allemandes sont en retraite passer par
une très grosse retraite c'est possible
de napoléon en 1812 c'est une retraite
de l'ordre de 150 à 200 km qui coûte
cher en terme de matériel mois en termes
d'hommes et qui n'aboutit pas à ce que
voulaient staline c'est à dire renverser
complètement la vapeur et ramener les
amants si possible sur la frontière de
1941 donc eu pour hitler la cites
question est simple dès que le beau
temps arrive rebelote on essaye de
refaire alors barrosa dans le sud il a
changé sur l'objectif cette fois su ce
n'est plus une grade et mousse ou ce
sera bakou les pétroles du caucase en
coupant les robinets ils pensent qu'ils
aimaient l'armée rouge à sec donc ça il
a changé l'objectif c'est pas logique
politique c'est l'objectif directement
économique staline de son côté a était
déçu par cette contre attaque qui certes
a sauvé sa capitale mais n'a pas
entraîné la destruction de l'armée
allemande au contraire c'est l'armée
rouge il s'est littéralement seigner à
force d'attaquer dans tous les sens
c'est un peu n'importe comment en
l'hiver 41 42 il a donc en quarts en
avril 42 une véritable un véritable
problème de définir ce qu'il veut qu'est
ce qu'il veut en 42 et ce qu'il définit
et il le fait en terme gatif il ne veut
pas que se reproduise l' attaque
surprise en plein été de 41 il veut
éviter un deuxième barbarossa aussi
demande-t-il à ses maréchaux de harceler
les allemands pour les empêcher d'être
en mesure de recommencer la même affaire
en 42 d'où une série de réunions
complètement alors seulement délirante
où staline demande à chacun des
maréchaux mais toi qu'est ce que tu me
proposes danton danton secteur pour
affaiblir les allemands donc évidemment
tout le monde va lui proposer d'attaqué
alors que ses principaux conseillers
vasilyev qui chapeaute lykov il devait
pas du tout l'armée rouge et aux faibles
attendons refaisons l'eau forme
barricadons nous résistants pied à pied
aux allemands et quand le mauvais temps
reviendra on contacte nouvelle fois
finalement on arrive à mi à une solution
mi chèvre mi chou il accepte de laisser
tomber la plupart des offensives sauf à
kharkov et là à kharkov il faut dire que
les soviétiques sont en avantage
numérique ils sont plus nombreux ils
sont coin 600 milles contre 350 millions
61 de chars et d'avions ils sont bien
supérieurs ils sont supérieurs aussi
donc a priori on se dit alors ça peut
marcher cependant il ya des réticences
et ailleurs c'est très intéressant j'ai
encore une fois remarque comme vu
comment fonctionnait le système de
commandement de l'armée soviétique
oulala la personnalité de staline est
vraiment écrasante et empêche chez la
plupart des reflex professionnel north
bruins ont peur de lui ils ont perdu ils
sont terrorisés peut-être à l'exception
de joukovski à son franc parler mais qui
sait jusqu'où ne pas aller trop loin en
tout cas toujours est il que ces
timochenko timochenko qui dirige cette
partie du fond donc le soin le front sud
ouest et en france à venir a st groupe
d'armées ans dans le langage militaire
soviétique timoshenko lui propose à
staline de reprendre kharkov je reviens
un petit peu en arrière en janvier 40 42
au plus fort de l'hiver timochenko a
déjà essayé de rendre karpov ça c'est
pas si mal placé et ça s'est traduit par
l'apparition d'un gros saillant dans
lequel les soviétiques ont massé des
troupes et il espère qu'à partir de
saillans combinée à une attaque par le
nord ils vont pouvoir fermer un étau et
reprendre kharkov qui posons que
timochenko pense que ce qu'il a n'a pas
réussi en janvier 42
ils veulent réussir en mai 42 et il
convainc sa ligne de le suivre dans
cette dent dans cette aventure sauf
qu'ils organisent extrêmement mal ces
choses timochenko si vous permettez un
portrait rapide du bonhomme c'est un
héros de cet art héros de la guerre il a
été immortalisé par isaac babel la
cavalerie rouge est un des grands romans
de
l'épopée de la guerre civile c'est un
espèce de colosse au crâne rasé c'est un
compagnon de staline de la première
heure donc c'est très noble c'est un
type de staline ce qui c'est possible
c'est un intime de staline c'est un
homme qui connaît qui sait ce qu'il en
coûte de s'opposer à staline et il il
souffre d'un complexe vis-à-vis de la
nouvelle étoile montante de l'armée
rouge qui n'étaient pas sains lui à
grand héros de la guerre civile qui a
déjoué cov et se joue kof qui a réussi
la chose extraordinaire de battre la
wehrmacht sous moscou timochenko en
prend ombrage on a beau être un camarade
maréchal soviétique on n'en reste pas
moins un homme dont il essaie de redorer
son blason et il pousse au maximum pour
cette offensive mal lui en a pris oui
effectivement quelques erreurs vont
commettre les rues cela parce que la
supériorité tactique et opérationnel des
allemands à bennett elle et elle est
habitable à les nets et les nets il ya
un certain nombre d'erreurs je n'aurais
pas être trop technique mais je dirais
que essentiellement le problème il est
presque évident nature politico
militaire c'est qu'en gros là maintenant
vous avez deux fronts cette affaire deux
groupes de front qui sont dirigés par un
seul homme c'est en cet homme c'est
petit motion qui saluèrent que
timochenko qui a un tout petit état
major et je crois qu'il a une douzaine
de fichiers derrière lui doit gérer un
million deux cent mille hommes des
centaines de milliers de véhicules
concrètement ça n'est pas possible il ne
peut pas assurer la coordination de ces
deux fronts il a donc se concentrer sur
le front du sud-ouest celui qui doit
mener la bataille en temps d'arrêt
contre kharkov et il va négliger l'autre
front celui du sud qui est commandée par
une future étoile de l'armée rouge
malinowski et il va il allait is à ne
pas exercer de surveillance sérieuse sur
malinowski or malinoski est chargé de
garder le flanc sud de cette attaque
et c'est là que c'est là que le bât
blesse c'est que tandis que la taxe se
déclenche à peu près normalement au nord
et au sud au nord ça patine mais au sud
ça se développe pas si mal les allemands
qui ont un service d'observation
aérienne bien supérieur à celui des
soviétiques voit bien qu'il ya quelque
chose qui va pas dans leur dispositif il
ya une masse qui avancent qu'il ya une
aile qui dort finale qui dort et qui
vise le monde sait pas partie fier donc
évidemment leur plan il faut pas leur en
laissait beaucoup en quelques jours le
plan a dressé la contre attaque va
surgir du sud elle est foudroyante
allait mener avec des moyens qui sont
pourtant pas extraordinaire elle va
couper en deux le saillant elle va
prendre ses trois cent mille soldats
soviétiques au filet et là elle va les
broyer les concasser et témoignages que
je rapporte sont absolument épouvantable
c'est un massacre c'est une grande
plaine
500 couverts où les soldats sont livrés
à l'armée secrète des allemands et je
crois que ça c'est la grande explication
de la victoire allemande c'est la loose
stuff la supériorité aérienne les
soviétiques n'ont pas encore un outil
est rien à la hauteur d'ailleurs je
pense que c'est ce sera cette médiocrité
des soviétiques dans le domaine aérien
ils vont traîner jusqu'en 1945 ils
n'arriveront jamais à égaler ce qu'il ya
en face
au moins en y arrivant qu'en jouant sur
la basse quand ils seront à 10 contre 1
évidemment mais là ils sont pas à 10
contre un ils sont au départ à 4 contre
1 et n'arrive à rien puis après ils sont
un contre un et la luftwaffe fait une
démonstration extraordinaire empêchent
tout mouvement
tout contre attaque domine totalement le
ciel et timochenko
alors il a la possibilité d'arrêter les
frais c'est à dire d'arrêter de
s'engouffrer vers l'ouest en exposant
toujours plus son flanc sud timochenko
qui a encore le temps de réagir de faire
demi tour parce qu'il sait qu'à des
concentrations ne fait rien et là je ne
vois pas d'autre explication que la peur
mais n'a pas de sara lee la peur de dire
à staline je me suis trompé je croyais
que les allemands étaient faibles j'ai
donné dans un point fort
je croyais que nouveau corps blindé
étaient supérieurs à leurs divisions
première j'ai eu tort je pensais que mon
aviation était à la hauteur j'ai eu tort
je pensais que malinowski elle est
vraiment faire son travail
je les ai pas surveillé et j'ai encore
une fois eu tort donc il tarde il ne
donne pas l'ordre de retraite évidemment
il fait le jeu des allemands qui sait à
la tête des forces allemandes de alors
du côté allemand on a alors le patron du
groupe d'armées sud c'est von boch celui
qui a été battue devant moscou en
décembre 40 41 le feu le maréchal von
boch mais les deux opérationnel s'est
pas au loup ce dont le nom fera le tour
du monde quelques mois plus tard puisque
ce pas au loup ce sera le patron la
sixième armée qui serait encerclé des
frites à stalingrad et où ceux de la
première pente gérardmer forme christ
qui est aussi un futur fait lemarchal et
qui est un excellent spécialiste les
panzers sauve en ce moment à faire à des
gens
conséquence ça va avoir pour la suite de
la guerre cette victoire allemande eh
bien ça laisse apparaître un trou béant
dans le dispositif soviétique un trou
énorme il ya trois cent mille âmes tueur
disparu ce de corps blindé tout neuf
entièrement ré équiper qui ont disparu
dans le maelström et staline va
récupérer tout ce qui peu partout pour
boucher le trou mais en réalité le tissu
est complètement déchiré or prospal plus
tard
claire déclenché le plan blau c'est à
dire la grande marche dans le caucase
stalingrad et l'a véritablement il a
donné car il a qu'à donner un petit coup
de boule dans la porte pour effondré
tout le flanc sud en réalité la marche à
stalingrad elle a commencé à kharkov
c'est aussi pour ça que c'est
intéressant
et ça aussi un autre intérêt c'est que
goebbels un qui a le nez creux pour ces
choses-là utiliser cette victoire qui
est la première victoire très franche
des allemands depuis plusieurs mois pour
dire à son peuple sahraoui j'ai consulté
tous les rapports et les services de
sécurité de la ss en dresser à goebbels
et hitler il est très clair que le moral
du peuple allemand remonte en flèche à
ce moment là on se remet à croire en la
possibilité de là à la supériorité du
intrinsèque du soldat allemand et à la
possibilité à la possibilité de vaincre
cette armée rouge
staline il est un peu ridicule dans
cette histoire mais vous dites il fait
pas fusiller timochenko 1 il leur est
fait avant il aurait fait un an 41 ils
l'affectent pavlov inquiets qui était un
col en général extrêmement important
chef de front il ne le fait plus parce
que il a quand même compris et a compris
quelque chose de fondamental staline et
tout ce qu'on veut mais pas un imbécile
il a parfaitement compris qu'il y avait
un déficit d'expérience non pas de la
trahison mais un déficit d'expérience
chez ces grands chefs il leur donne le
temps d'attendre leur donne neuf ans
d'apprendre et il accepte de leur
laisser ce temps d'apprentissage mais il
va changer les règles du jeu ça c'est
une des grandes conséquences de la
bataille de kharkov c'est à partir de là
il va systématiquement utiliser comme
comme carnot en la révolution française
avec les envoyer les les envoyer en
mission il va utiliser des envoyés
spéciaux de la staf cas ils seront
toujours les deux mêmes hommes on se les
deux plus grosses têtes de la seconde
guerre mondiale à l'aise zhukov vassili
skis qui vont systématiquement être
me par staline dans tous les endroits où
ça chauffe pour assurer les coordination
entre les différents chefs être l'oeil
de moscou avec carte blanche complète
c'est-à-dire parler au nom de staline
évidemment ils sèment la terreur en même
temps ils vont être d'une efficacité
redoutable parce que ce sont deux très
grands chefs qui les premiers ont
comprend ont compris l'importance du
contrôle et du commandement dans l'armée
dans la guerre moderne il sait pas par
hasard si à partir de kharkov staline
systématiquement vais les envoyer en
pompiers partout ça va chauffer et on le
retrouvera plus ce défaut de
coordination où chacun attaques dans son
coin dans un dans un chaos un désordre
assez simple le belge est un des
meilleurs spécialistes de la seconde
guerre mondiale sur le front de l'est
qu'est ce qui fait que cette armée rouge
c'est une véritable catastrophe en 1941
qui est battus et rebattus
par les allemands va devenir absolument
invincible
quelques mois quasiment plus tard
il ya le commandement on l'a dit avait
été décapité par staline avant même la
guerre a au moment des proches et là
tout à coup ils se retrouvent aider avec
des barres et chaud vous citez qui
deviennent de mieux en mieux le très bon
alors il ya plusieurs causes mais il y
en a une qui est toujours été
systématiquement passer sous silence
parce que au fond que personne ne le
savait à l'époque les allemands moins
que les autres c'est que le haut
commandant celui éthique c'est à dire à
peu près le milieu de généraux
qu'on appelle la classe 1940 et 1980 de
généraux sont tous passés par là
l'académie de guerre de l'école de
guerre de l'armée rouge à l'académie
woods est hélas ils ont eu pour maîtres
de très grands penseurs
les gens qui sont d'une dimension
extraordinaire comme suit chine qui a
peu clause 8 20e siècle et qui ont une
coupe une conception révolutionnaire de
la façon dont on peut amener les
opérations ces gens ont été dressés à ce
qu'on appelle à opératif en russe katya
ils se couchent vollard opératif qui est
mais ils n'ont pas l'outil en 41 cet
outil va se loger dans l'expérience mais
une fois que cet outil s'éroder que les
matériels affluent sans oublier l'aide
des anglo-américains extrêmement
importants notamment en termes
d'aviation et en termes de transport une
fois que l'outil
a acquis l'expérience a pris la mesure
de son terrible adversaire
à ce moment là cette supériorité
intellectuelle du commandement
soviétique va commencer à s'exprimer
dans une série d'offensives qui vont
être de mieux en mieux mener de mieux en
mieux coordonner et qui vont ne vont pas
laisser un seul instant de répit à
l'armée allemande jusqu'à la prise de
berlin où ça évidemment au prix d'une
d'une saignée extraordinaire parce que
cet apprentissage pour les soviétiques
il a un coût terrible c'est 11 à 12
millions de militaires tués pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale je ne parle pas
des civils françois guillaume lorrain 1
et 2 choses moi qui me frappe c'est c'la
on revisite un peu quand même
ce qu'on pense de staline comme chef de
guerre c'est par rapport à été on les a
toujours comparer l'un à l'autre c'est y
en a qui est complètement sourd et il y
en a un qui quand même
comme vous le décrivez très bien
apprenti par écouter fini par écouter
comme vous dites donne du temps donne de
l'expérience et à une subtilité quand
même qui semble le plus importante dans
les affaires de commandement donc ça
c'est peut-être aussi parce que il pour
hitler ça avait bien commencé oui mais
voilà et et pour staline c'est à très
mal pour remonter la pente et donc il
faut tirer des leçons d'un échec la
terrible il ya une autre chose vous
parliez tout à l'heure au début de la
résonance mémorielle faible voire nulle
et je me demandais si c'est pas parce
que chronologiquement ça arrive entre
vous c'est très bien que dans dans une
guerre bon on peut pas prendre tous les
sommes yade il ya des creux et des
sommets et c'est entre deux sommets
moscou et stalingrad après viendra la
toujours sublime stalingrad et moscou
qui règne dans l'imaginaire ne peut
hélas une gravure raison c'est le
mémorial mans c'est pas possible ça ne
se passe pas la bataille de champagne en
1915 entre la marne et verdun alors
aucune chance d'exister en mémoire on a
beaucoup de cas comme ça mais pour
staline je dirais france je suis arrivé
après vingt ans à étudier ce truc cette
conclusion que les lionceaux l'éthique a
vraiment failli perdre à cause de ce
talent et non les erreurs du début de ce
que nous voyons c'est dans mes gènes
mais qu'elle a gagné grâce à lui en
bonne partie parce que finalement
il était indispensable au système qu'il
avait créé autour de lui s'il avait
disparu ci s'est effondré comme on
l'avait prétendu un moment de façon
durable on dit qu'il se serait tourné
c'est faux tout début aujourd'hui on
sait que ses fans de trois jours non une
journée une journée où il disparaît dans
sa villa de kun c'est beau mais c'est
faux il a on a le carnet aujourd'hui le
carnet de a été publiée par les par les
russes le carnet de rendez vous au
kremlin il travaille comme un fou il n'y
a pas de passage à vide un homme qui
reçoit 40 spécialistes dans la journée
c'est pas un homme qui est en dépression
c'est pas vrai il n'a jamais lâché les
rênes et il a le système est tellement
fait autour de lui que s'il avait foule
s'il avait flanché tout s'effondrait je
pense qu'une soviétique ne pouvait pas
tenir mais il a tenu il a tenu et il a
su mobiliser autour autour de lui son
peuple et le miracle c'est que même
la majorité du peuple soviétique dont je
pense qu'elle s'est profondément pour
des raisons valables qui sont celles de
la collectivisation forcée des campagnes
dans les années 30 a fini par se rallier
à lui parce que ce qui est proposé en
face était probablement encore pire
c'était ça la mauvaise surprise des
russes c'est qu'il était possible
d'avoir pire que le stalinisme c'était
le nazisme est ce qu'il n'ya pas aussi
le fait que le communisme soviétique tel
qu'on le connaissait ça marche pas en
temps de paix mais sa marche en avant en
vendent bien c'est un système guérini au
fond ce système qui est fait pour les
coups durs pour la tempête qui est fait
pour les guerres civiles ont les
mobilisations massives obtenir tel objet
qui fait un autre le maoïsme était un
peu comme ça aussi on sait mobiliser les
masses on se préoccupe pas du coup ça
coûte ce que ça coûte mais on arrivera
et on s'est mobilisé le parti communiste
a inventé toutes les grandes techniques
de manipulation et d'encadrement des
masses à ça ça évident c'est quelque
chose à quoi ils quittent leur n'a pas
n'a pas mesuré politiquement le seul qui
a senti que cette chose là et quand on
lit son journal on est fasciné c'est
goebbels goebbels qui à mesure que la
guerre avance critiques de moins en
moins les soviétiques et est de plus en
plus admiratif au point qu'en 1942 dans
son journal un jour il va chez hitler et
il y passe un film d'actualité qu'il a
récupéré par ses services au mexique qui
vient des états unis et qui montre la
défense de leningrad saint film qui a
été remonté par les américains en 1945
41 42 et qui montrent la défense des
migrants et tous les deux se regarde le
soir se regardent et et hitler d'après
d'après goebel se dit et ce qu'on serait
capable de salou et en 45 quand les
soviétiques rentrer en allemagne ici le
rêve de goebbels et transformer chaque
ville en leningrad ça marche pas tout
kharkov 1942 ça vient de paraître chez
perrin
merci tous les deux d'avoir participé à
cette émission scarlett de françois
guillaume lorrain c'est chez flammarion
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]